Hast du beim Netz irgendwas anders als letztes Jahr?
Ich bin auf LTE, keine Ahnung.
Also es ist mit dem WLAN an sich, also ich weiß nicht ganz genau, wie so eure Erfahrungen sind. Mann, heute ist aber auch hier wirklich der Wurm drin.
Ich hab jetzt langsam echt keinen Bock mehr.
Das ist aber nicht der Nachfolger von Goatzi.
Könnte aber sein.
Aber klick mal.
Es wird immer größer.
Es hört irgendwann auf. Du musst wirklich wollen.
More to come soon. Jetzt muss man da wieder draufklicken.
Und von da wirst du jetzt...
Das ist was für die Pessimisten, oder?
Ne, tatsächlich verbirgt sich hinter diesen Links jeweils weitere... Also wie das Web ursprünglich mal gedacht war. Man folgt halt diesen Links und man klickt immer weiter. Und irgendwie nach einer halben Stunde, wenn man dieses blank.org immer weiterklickt, dann landet man definitiv an einem Ort, wo man dachte nie gewesen sein zu wollen.
Ist das der vierte Link?
Alle Links führen...
An diesen Ort.
An beliebige Punkte der Matrix.
Du kannst mich jetzt ja sozusagen noch stoppen.
Ich würde sagen Cliffhanger. Jeder probiert das einfach selber aus und berichtet dann uns Twitter oder in den Blogkommentaren von der Freak Show, wo sie gelandet sind. Aber blank.org ist tatsächlich so ein Klassiker, den nicht viele kennen. Hand hoch, wer kannte blank.org?
Keiner.
Online-Experte. Das ist mein erster Web-Tipp jetzt.
Das erinnert mich ein bisschen an einen alten Sport, den wir damals in Kaufhäusern betrieben haben. Damals, als das der einzige Ort war, wo man an einen Computer rankam. Jetzt kommt wieder so Old-Fahrt-Material.
Auto-Exec-Bad löschen und...
Da gab es auch noch keine Auto-Exec-Bad.
Nein, C64.
C64, genau.
Weil die C64 standen ja immer so offen rum. Und...
Mussten wir dein Basic aushalten. Und die Schleife, die du dann probiert hast.
Ja, genau. Wir haben dann so Pranks programmiert. Das heißt, wir haben Programme geschrieben, die dann genauso aussahen wie der normale Startscreen. Und wenn dann irgendwelche Kunden sich das erste Mal an diesen Computer herantrauten und eine Taste drücken, passierten immer ganz grausame Dinge. Und wurden dann irgendwie erschreckt. Dann haben wir uns dann immer so hinter den, ja, haben uns dann immer so versteckt und das angeschaut. Das macht man halt so allmacht als Jugendlicher. Ich mein, das war, wir hatten ja nichts. Ja, macht ihr das mal klar.
Nicht mal Blue-Screens.
82.
Nichts.
Kein Internet.
Da wurde ich gerade geboren.
Huckel wurde gerade geboren.
Ja, wir hatten ja nichts. Wir haben ja Huckel.
Nicht mal Huckel hatten wir. So, aber so ein bisschen sowas wie blank.org hat es halt auch, weil wenn du das jetzt Leuten einfach so einstellst, dann so, mein Pixel ist kaputt. Ja, und dann noch drauf rumklicken, dann können halt Dinge passieren.
Einer meiner Lieblingskollegen-Scherze ist ja immer, einen Screenshot von ihrem Desktop zu machen, und das als Hintergrundbild einzurichten und alle Ordner dazu verstecken sozusagen, um dann zu beobachten, wie sie zu ihrem Rechner zurückkehren und festzustellen, dass es offensichtlich einen Freeze gab und jetzt die nächste Amtshandlung ein Reboot wäre, um dann genau wieder in den gleichen Screens zu kommen. Es sind die einfachen Freuden. Was ist denn, habt ihr denn noch irgendeine Webseite, die ihr noch nie anderen Leuten empfohlen habt, die ihr aber gelegentlich, also so eine ganz obskure, so ganz hinten in der Ecke?
Nicht so auf die Schnelle.
Ich bin enttäuscht.
Windows 93.net. Das ist doch ein Mac-Podcast.
Das ist natürlich so ein bisschen gefährlich, wenn man jetzt einfach irgendwelche URLs nennen lassen, weil man weiß ja nie, was dabei draus kommt.
Aber wenn das jetzt schlecht ist... Ach, das Ende des Internets.
Aber ob das wirklich das Ende ist?
Ich hatte früher ja mal... Mir kamen ja mal so... Ich hab so verhinderte Kunstprojekte, wo ich ehrlich gesagt furchtbar traurig bin über jedes einzelne, was ich nicht realisiert habe. Ich muss gleich noch mal ein bisschen kramen. Aber ich hatte irgendwie relativ früh so die Idee eines Online-Müll-Eimers, wo man einfach so seine Daten entsorgen konnte.
Online?
Ja, also du löschst halt was.
So wie diese Schredder...
Und sie haben Ipoh gemacht oder wie auch immer und heißen jetzt hier Dropbox?
Da sammelt man dann halt einfach so... Es war halt Kunst, also das muss sozusagen... Ich war mir jetzt nicht mehr so ganz so sicher, in welchem Jahr das war, in Abhängigkeit davon, muss man ja dann immer so ein bisschen justieren, was irgendwie cool ist und was nicht. Weil manchmal sagt man ja so Dinge voraus oder findet sie dann so total lustig und dann später wird einem so gewahr auf Weier. Also ich weiß noch, als das allererste Mal im CCC so von außen die Anfrage kam, ja sagen sie mal, sie kennen sich doch aus, kann man denn per E-Mail sich ein Virus einfangen? Und wir alle so, das geht nie! Weil wer würde denn auf die Idee kommen, an ein E-Mail ein Programm anzuhängen, was dann auch noch automatisch ausgeführt wird? Und dann haben die das alles implementiert und dann sind diese ganzen furchtbaren Dinge dann auch immer noch entstanden, wo man sich halt vorher überhaupt nicht vorstellen konnte, dass es so ist. Und ich glaube, genauso ist das jetzt hier auch so mit unserem aktuellen Pessimismus, dass hier ganze Zeit einfach so Dinge passieren, von denen wir irgendwie gar nicht dachten, dass es irgendwie passieren kann.
Das ist schlimmer als unsere Vorstellung.
Ja, weil wir sind eigentlich alle Optimisten und verbessern dich geradezu. Guck mal, was haben wir denn immer postuliert? Ja, Internet, wenn das dann mal kommt und alle sich austauschen können, das ist ja eine Happy Family, dann gehen die Ideen von A nach B und alle denken so, oh ja, warum ich denn da noch nicht drauf gekommen bin? Das ist ja eine hervorragende Gedanke, da könnten wir ja alle in Frieden miteinander und so.
Aber wenn alle miteinander und so die Krankheiten, du weißt schon.
Ja, das Problem ist halt nur, dass irgendwie alle Leute, die mal wirklich ihre Ideen austauschen sollten, immer so, ah, Internet, lass mich in Frieden, ich hab irgendwie mein Buch.
Mein Almanach.
Und die Leute, an die wir nicht gedacht haben, die sind jetzt irgendwie da und tauschen ihre Ideen aus und schon ist die Kacke am Dampfen. Das ist das Problem. Und deswegen müssen wir jetzt halt eigentlich irgendwie gegensteuern. Also irgendwas müssen wir machen.
Das hat Edward Snowden auch gesagt.
Du musst halt den Arsch hochkriegen.
Ja, das hat er auch gesagt.
Ja, aber jetzt sitzen wir hier, ne? Und Roddy auch noch auf dem Einhorn.
Roddy, du sagst irgendwie gar nichts. Bist du eigentlich schon betrunken?
Sein Mikro ist nicht an.
Soweit ich weiß nicht wieso, wollte ich noch was trinken.
Was hast du denn dabei?
Die Freak Show Ultras haben uns...
Vielleicht wird es ja doch noch lustig.
Die Freak Show Ultras.
Ich wollte ja jetzt nicht mehr so viel besaufen. Ach so, da fällt mir eigentlich...
Der vom letzten Jahr, der war so übel.
Mexikaner? Wir werden doch noch betrunken. Aber wir haben keine Glä...
Doch.
Lasst mich raus.
Bisschen Luft für das Einhorn wäre auch gut.
Hier, füll mal ein bisschen ein.
Geil, Mexikaner.
Guck mal, was ich hier am Info-Tresen bekommen habe. Und so haben sie mir gesagt, dass wäre eigentlich das Original-Design hier für den Kongress gewesen. Können wir das irgendwo in die Kamera halten? Wo ist der Kameramann?
Wo ist der Kameramann? Dann mach mal hier Fotobus an oder sowas.
Irgendwo ranhalten.
Mit dem guten deutschen Teenage.
Fotobus. Hier, näher, so.
Und jetzt da auf den Schirm.
Achso, warte mal, wir müssen das, äh, sorry.
Hier ist noch Windows 93, das war ja jetzt nicht so unterhaltsam.
Da muss man bestimmt klicken, deswegen.
Da muss man bestimmt klicken, das mach ich aber jetzt nicht.
Vielleicht gibt's zuerst mal einen.
Das könnt ihr dann zu Hause machen.
Und jetzt, äh, jetzt bin ich gerade verwirrt. Wo ist meine Maus? Hier. Wo ist meine Maus?
Ich krieg die Maus, ich krieg die Maus.
So, ich bin onscreen.
Fullscreen.
Geht das?
Dein Einsatz.
Fullscreen, kannst du das nicht größer machen?
Äh, gute Frage.
Ja, also.
So hier.
Und ist jetzt doppelt gespiegelt.
Angeblich soll...
Das ist geil.
Die umgedrehte Schrift, die nicht umgedreht ist, ist natürlich jetzt wieder umgedreht und dann heißt es MROVSKROV. MROVSKROV.
Großartig.
Auf dem Essay.
Was hat er eigentlich da am Kopf? Ein Pfeil im Kopf?
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Ein Pinsel oder so.
Ein Wolf. Was ist das? In einem Hoodie.
Mit Pfeil im Kopf.
Wenn du diese Botschaft irgendwie von hinten liest, dann könnte sie...
Um mit 66,6 Umdrehungen pro Minute gespielt werden.
Gefährliche Botschaften enthalten. Emrovskroff. Das ist jetzt sozusagen unser Codewort. Ihr könnt ja mal versuchen, das irgendwo an so einem Ding einzugehen. Ach so, das ist ja bisher nicht eifernumerisch.
Gibt's am Info-Tresen für 2,50? Das ist hier zum Aufbügeln. Das ist jetzt hier Qualitätsware.
Emrovskroff.
Für die Hackerkutte.
Mexikaner.
Das wär's eigentlich noch. Du hast so die richtigen Podcast-Fans, die mit so einer Jeans-Weste rumlaufen und von jedem Podcast das Logo so draufgestickt haben. Und dann zu den Live-Events gehen und Neues einsammeln.
Aber dann bitte mit Schal.
Wir müssen mal echt an unserem Merchandising arbeiten.
Da sind wir eigentlich ziemlich weit hinten.
Das haben wir nicht nötig.
Ist eher Faulheit, ehrlich gesagt. Ein bisschen Verpeiltheit, um genauer zu sein.
Also langsam sitze ich hier ganz auf dem Boden. Aber das macht nichts.
Dein Einhorn entweicht die Luft oder was?
Das ist nicht mein Einhorn. Das ist das Einhorn von den Podcast-Party-Nen.
Wie hieß es noch gleich?
Clemens.
Clemens, genau.
Oder Carrie.
Das hat mehrere Namen.
Oder Timme.
Clemens Fischer nennen wir es.
Es gibt eine Luftpumpe auch.
Clemens Fischer. Was für ein romantischer Name für ein Einhorn.
Prost.
Stößchen auf die Zukunft.
Auf den Berufsoptik. Hast du schon getrunken?
Huckel schummelt schon wieder.
Huckel hat das irgendwo hingegossen.
Nee, nee.
Ist ein geiles Zeug.
Sehr würzig.
Wenn beim Inder nicht scharf genug ist, dann macht man sich das da rein.
Kann ich den Foto-Boost wieder ausmachen?
Von wem war das?
Von den Freak Show Ultras.
Die wollen uns umbringen.
Nee, Mexikaner ist super. Mexikaner kommt gleich nach Jägermeister.
Aber letztes Jahr war das nicht so scharf.
Das Hamburger Mundfeuerwerk.
Oder ich war...
Ist aber Klassik, ich weiß nicht, wie hot ist.
Gibt es hot auch noch?
War so eine Vermutung.
Hot or not? Mundfeuerwerk...
Hier steht er sicher.
Mundfeuerwerk kann breit machen und führt zu schärfer Reiz auf der Zunge.
Was steht hier drauf?
Passt.
So wie die Freak Show.
Kann auch breit machen.
Hast du eigentlich unsere Sendungsnummer angekündigt?
Ja.
Und? Nee, hast du nicht? Welche Nummer?
190.
Wann machen wir die Vorstellungsrunde?
Hatten wir eigentlich schon mal eine Fragestunde?
Ich war vorhin schon dabei, zu erklären, wer alles nicht da ist. Das ist so gut gelungen. Dann kam Clemens trotzdem wieder dazwischen. Nein, natürlich haben wir uns vorgestellt. Wir haben uns, wie der Nerd sagt, implizit vorgestellt. Man kann sich implizit und man kann sich explizit vorstellen. Und das ist auch sehr hilfreich. Ich finde, implizites Vorstellen ist auch sehr freundlich. Weil ihr kennt ja alle dieses Verpeilteilsproblem, wenn man um den Kongress rumläuft, und dann wieder so, oh Gott, doller Gesicht, doller Name und dann so irgendwie select from where.
Du meinst, wenn sich beide treffen, beide wissen nicht mehr, wie der andere heißt, und dann kurz sagen, ja und, wie findest du das? Ja, wir sehen uns später als Clashbook und dann sehen sie sich genau ein Jahr später erst wieder.
Nee, ich finde, man kann den Leuten nicht unbedingt immer zumuten, dass sie einen erkennen und zugeordnet bekommen, weil man das ja auch von sich selbst kennt, dass man das immer nicht so kann. Und wenn man dann halt in so einer Situation ist, dann kann man dann schon versuchen, das sozial auszugleichen, indem man dann zum Beispiel so ein bisschen verklemmt in so einer dritten Person von sich redet. Ich geh zur Bar und denk mir noch, ey Timmer, jetzt ein Mexikaner.
Ach, ich dachte so wie die anonymen Hacker. Mein Name ist Roddy und ich, nein.
Dann musst du irgendwie in Geständnis kommen jetzt.
Ja, das Dumme an implizit ist halt, ne?
Sieht übrigens ganz schön albern aus, jetzt wo das Einhorn die ganze Zeit Luft verliert. Du könntest natürlich jetzt auch noch so ein bisschen versuchen, drauf zu reiten oder so.
Das ist privat.
Hast du ein Verhältnis zu Einhörnern? Also ich meine, gib dir das was? Verbindest du was mit Einhörnern?
Hat dir das Einhorn was gegeben?
Ich mag das Einhorn.
Du magst das Einhorn, das ist sehr schön.
Ich hab's auch gleich auf meine Amazon-Wunschliste getan. Ernsthaft?
Natürlich.
Was kostet das?
Guck halt nach.
Aber hast du die entsprechenden Räumlichkeiten? Würdest du dein Bett rausschmeißen und dafür dann auf dem Einhorn?
Mein Bett ist groß genug, das Einhorn kann mit ins Bett.
Ach ja, wie romantisch. Das Bild krieg ich nie wieder aus dem Kopf.
Roddy und sein süßes Einhorn. Warum ist das nicht pink? Obwohl hier ist es bunt.
Da?
Ach Mensch, das ist doch hier alles total überflüssig. Wollen wir noch aufhören oder wollen wir irgendwas interessantes erzählen?
Hast du denn noch was? Ich?
Ja, ich muss immer liefern. Ich sag euch immer so, lasst mal eine Sendung machen und dann so, ja, können wir schon machen. Aber so vorbereiten ist nicht.
Ich hab was genötet.
Ja.
Oh jetzt, Roddy wacht auf. Roddy rettet jetzt die Sendung.
Na ja, du hast was gelötet.
Na das heißt, wie heißt denn das? Ardu Touch Synthesizer.
Es wird gelb, es wird gelb.
Was heißt das?
Leute verlassen das Gebäude.
Die Luft ist besser.
Der CO2-Sensor. Na das ist so ein Ardu Inu ähnliches Teil mit so...
Soll das ein Klavier sein?
Ja, mit so Klaviertasten. Ein Strom-Lautsprecher-Einschalter und so... Ich zieh jetzt mal hier den Stecker raus von dem blauen Kabel. Man steckt den hier ein. Schauen wir mal.
So, und jetzt wird der Regler wieder hochgezogen.
Achso, jetzt muss ich noch einschalten.
Was hast du damit gemacht?
Ich hab die grüne Leuchttiode kaputt gemacht und dann eine weiße geschnort unten im Hackcenter. Nochmal vielen Dank, wer auch immer mehr die gegeben hat.
Das musst du unten in der Lounge testen, der Bass.
Auf dem Kopfhörer ist er gut.
Der Subwoofer wird Dinge auf dem Boden anfangen zu bewegen.
Bleibt noch gut.
Das ist ganz cool.
Das ist jetzt mit Arduino. Das ist kein SID von C64.
Das ist ATMEGA 328P. Wir spielen mal was.
Kannst du Klavier spielen?
Nö.
Hast du das hier auf dem Congress gelötet?
Den hab ich vorhin hier.
Probier's mal mit Multitouch.
Kann er nicht, ne?
Nee, ich glaub, das ist homophon. Ach so, und irgendwann stürzt er ab.
Sendungstitel.
Da waren schon so einige dabei.
Das war's schon?
Aber schön.
Hat doch Klang gemacht.
Schöner Ausklang.
Das kann man unten erwerben und dann kann man all diese Bauteile da drauflöten.
Und die grüne LED?
Ja, wenn man die nicht kaputt macht.
Wie hast du die kaputt gemacht? Zu heiß gelötet?
Ich hab die grüne erst dahin gelötet, wo die blaue sein sollte. Und dann hab ich sie versucht wieder auszulöten und dabei ist sie kaputt gegangen. Aber ich war zu verplant.
Was wünschen wir uns denn fürs neue Jahr? Also abgesehen jetzt von dem Optimismus und der allgemeinen Weltrettung.
Noch mehr?
Hast du Wünsche?
Ja, noch mehr Mexikaner.
Das geht noch dieses Jahr.
Irgendwas mit Holz.
Das wär jetzt deine Gelegenheit gewesen.
Na ja, du hast ja schon die großen Kaninchen aus dem Stall geholt, ne? Mit Weltfrieden und was war das andere? Alles wird besser?
Ich glaube, es ist ein Wünsche, ich bin Optimist, da bin ich irgendwie unverbesserlich.
Das ist schlimm, aber damit müsst ihr klarkommen jetzt.
Keine Ahnung, vielleicht wünscht er ja irgendwas für unser Format. Wohin es so gehen soll, was wir zur 200. Sendung machen sollen.
Mehr Einhörner.
Roddy, du bist irgendwie monohomo...
Homothematisch.
Homothematisch, genau.
Sendung müssen wir Party machen. Ja?
Das finde ich allerdings auch. Und Haus abbrennen.
Wenn wir diese Kopfhörer kriegen, wäre das ein Incentive.
Kopfhörer-Party.
Ich bin dagegen. Ich will mich mit Leuten unterhalten.
Das kannst du ja auch.
Wieso? Sind an den Kopfhörern auch Hetsys?
Nein, ich muss...
Ich muss noch mal darauf zurückkommen, weil... Das war jetzt nicht so, dass da keine soziale Interaktion war, weil in diesem Raum war es still. Aber es gab natürlich trotzdem eine Bar und Leute, die halt nicht tanzten. Nur die Leute, die tanzten, hatten Kopfhörer auf und eingeschaltet. Aber wenn du halt keinen Bock auf Tanzen hast, bist du halt an die Bar gegangen und da war es halt total leise.
Ja, weil keiner was gesagt hat.
Und da konnte man sich halt wunderbar auch darüber unterhalten, welcher Farbe jetzt gerade nachgetanzt hat.
Also so den Stupid Small Talk und die Awkward Silence sind da voll ausgeprägt sozusagen.
Awkward Silence ist da default.
Man muss das weiter denken. Guck mal, wir sind ja Nerds. Das heißt, man sammelt natürlich erst mal diese Informationen. Wie viele Kopfhörer sind jetzt gerade auf welche Farbe eingeschaltet? Und das ist dann immer so eine, dann über die Zeit hast du dann eine entsprechende Skala. Man könnte ja dann auch sagen, wann auch immer eine Quelle, das muss ja jetzt nicht unbedingt Musik sein, wann auch immer eine Quelle quasi für einen Mindestzeitraum dann Popularität gewonnen hat, also die Mehrheit.
Aber bringt das so eine Party vorwärts?
Mann, das muss man doch erstmal ausprobieren! Was ist denn das immer für eine skeptische Scheiße?
Genau, man muss auch mal ausprobieren.
Immer dieses Internet, wozu brauche ich denn das Computer? Ja wo bleibt denn da der optimistische Blick?
Ich kann ja in die Zukunft gucken, da sehe ich doch, das macht genau eine Viertelstunde lang Spaß und dann ist das langweilig.
Das weißt du doch überhaupt nicht!
Ich kenn mich doch.
Das hast du wahrscheinlich von allem schon mal behauptet. Du hast aber nicht immer Recht behalten.
Ja, aber vielleicht ist die aufregendste Viertelstunde des Jahres.
Ich hab mich auch schon mit Sachen beschäftigt, wo er am Anfang dachte so...
War länger als eine Viertelstunde, stimmt schon.
Ja, aber ich hab auch ein paar andere Sachen mehr angeschaut. Ich weiß noch, wie ihr mich alle angeguckt habt, weil ich mit meinem ersten Podcast in den Club reingekommen und dann so, hier guckt mal, ist ganz toll, irgendwie spür ich das mal vor. Und alle so... Dann gibt's sicherlich was von Radio-Farmen.
Und das war wirklich so, ich kann mich an den Tag erinnern, als Tim in den Club gelaufen ist und gemeint hat, ich will jetzt nur noch Podcasts machen und alle so da saßen so... Na dann, viel Spaß!
Dieser Club war noch nie modern.
Das bedeutet gar nichts.
Ich zähl mir mit diesem 1 Kilo XML-Buch im Club rumgelaufenes Wochenlang.
Ja, das kommt mir auch bekannt vor.
Und hat sich weitergebracht.
Ja.
Und nicht nur XML, XSLT war auf jeden Fall auch da mit dabei.
Fucking Reddit!
So viel Sport hast du noch nie gemacht mit dem 1 Kilo, oder?
Abgesehen davon, dass es zwei echt sehr gute Bücher waren, die ich wirklich sehr intensiv gelesen habe.
Und hast du auch ein XSLT-Predigt bekommen?
Äh, ne, ich bin bestimmt immer geflüchtet vorher.
Aber XSLT war auf jeden Fall auch ein... war schon heiß. Für eine Viertelstunde.
Die Chaos Radio Webseite ist heute noch XSLT und das läuft immer noch, obwohl ich da irgendwie null Maintenance seit Jahren gemacht habe.
Und jetzt die spannende Preisfrage fürs Publikum. Wer von euch hat schon mal XSLT angewandt? Hunderte!
Davon gehört?
Und wer davon freiwillig?
Und wer hat überhaupt keine Ahnung, was XSLT ist?
Wer hat sich jetzt dreimal gemeldet? Ich hab's genau gesehen.
Hausaufgabe zur nächsten Sendung, ihr müsst das rausfinden.
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Es gibt halt einfach, es gibt schon so Perlen, da muss man halt auch gegen den Mainstream auch angeschwommen kommen. Ich meine, nur weil jetzt alle Java programmieren, heißt das ja noch lange nicht, dass das jetzt irgendwie eine geile Nummer ist. Oder?
Das würde ich voll und ganz unterschreiben.
Ja, siehst du mal, ne? Und vor allem sag das mal Java programmieren. Bist du also auf eine sehr kleine Minderheit, gucken die sich alle mit so einem beschämten Blick dann so an, so ja, wir machen das ja in der Firma.
Ich hab das halt auf der Uni gelernt. Sagen die ich, ich war ja nicht.
Ja, so was, genau, wir hatten ja nichts.
Genau, 64er, Java.
Genau, genau, das ist das Ding. Und deswegen muss man sich dagegen durchsetzen und muss dann halt auch in der Minderheiten-Position auch standhaft bleiben. Und dann ist das halt auch erfüllend. Also ich fand diese XML-XSLT-Nummer, das hat mich einfach total gekickt.
Ich weiß.
Nimm doch noch einen Schluck Mexikana.
Aber wo waren wir denn gerade stehen geblieben? Wir waren doch vorher noch bei irgendwas...
Zukunft und Technologie und...
Wir wollten das 2017, was wir da so erwarten.
Ah ja, genau. Was hast du denn für Wünsche?
Keine Ahnung. Gutes Wetter wär schon gar nicht schlecht.
XSLT setzt sich durch.
Nein, wir waren bei der Kopfhörer-Party und wir waren bei den Statistiken. Und dass man diesen Ding positiv aufgeschlossen gegenüber sein muss. Und ich sage einfach, erst mal machen...
Aber kannst du das nicht vorausziehen, dass das nicht lange spannend ist? Okay, anders, weil wir ja Umfragen machen. Wer von euch ist der der Meinung, dass das länger spannend ist als eine Party lang?
Das würde ja erst mal vollkommen ausreichen.
Das sind jetzt schon die Antworten oder überlegt ihr noch?
Bisher meldet sich noch niemand.
You've got no fucking evidence, man.
Der hat euch gerade beleidigt.
Nein, man muss das einfach mal alles ausprobieren. Sonst ist es doch nicht gut.
Ja, kann man ja auch.
Dieser ganze Kongress ist ein einziges Ausprobieren.
Seit 30 Jahren.
Ja, wenn sich alle sagen, ich weiß jetzt nicht, wenn ich das zusammenbaue, weiß ich jetzt wirklich nicht, ob mich das weiterbringt.
Das hab ich nicht gesagt. Das hast du jetzt umgedeutet. Aber LEDs am Kopfhörer, finde ich...
Es geht doch nicht um die LEDs. Es geht um die fucking Kommunikation.
Aber die hab ich auch auf einer normalen Party.
Es ist ein Gradmesser für dynamische Bewegung einer sozialen Gruppe.
Ja, ich weiß, du stehst ja auch statt.
Die du dann wiederum als Eingabe benutzt. Und damit hast du sozusagen einen Aufschaukelungsmoment. Du kannst eine Feedback-Schleife, eine soziale Feedback-Schleife erzielen.
Du musst jetzt noch Machine Learning sagen.
Für die drei Details ist vielleicht ganz cool. Das ist sozusagen die sozialen, menschlichen, humanoiden, homophonen Systeme, die beeinflussen sich sozusagen automatisch gegenseitig in Echtzeit.
Was ist das?
Und dann passieren unglaubliche Sachen.
Was ist denn das? Tim will ja auch schon immer, seit ich ihn kenne, seine Meinung parametrisieren. Das war eine der ersten Meetings, glaube ich, den ich bei gewohnt habe zum Congress, wo es so um Content-Meetings ging und das PentaBuff, also unser ursprüngliches Planungssystem, ja. Und da war auf jeden Fall auch schon der Wunsch der parametrisierten Meinung. Ganz präsent.
Ja, wir sind nicht weit gekommen. Doch, ich bin sehr weit gekommen, aber der Rest ist ja dann nicht mitgelaufen. Also ich war ja schon ganz weit vorn.
Oder ganz weit hinten.
Ich bin nach wie vor der Meinung, dass das alles durchaus überprüfenswert wäre. Und man muss... Ehrlich gesagt, also ich bin... Es gibt hier wirklich eine ganze Menge geile Sachen. Aber wenn wir davon ausgehen, dass wir hier softwaretechnisch schon die Gilde und ganz weit vorn wären, da gehe ich nicht mit.
Spreche jetzt etwa vom Tickel?
Nee, ich rede von allem. Also dafür, dass wir uns so viel mit Software beschäftigen und so viel mit Systemen beschäftigen, gibt es zwar an sich ganz gute Ergebnisse, aber gemessen an dem, was ich mir auch nur so im Ansatz vorstellen könnte, was man eigentlich erzielen könnte, ist da einfach noch eine ganze Menge zu gehen. Also man gibt sich schon doch teilweise recht früh zufrieden für meinen Geschmack.
Aber du hast ja das Coden schon lange aufgegeben.
Na ja, Gott, also ich meine, ich beschäftige mich immerhin...
Noch mit Lisp.
Die Frage ist nicht, ob man sich noch mit Lisp beschäftigt, sondern ob man sich schon mit Lisp beschäftigt.
Und außerdem, er macht mich wahnsinnig. Leute, wirklich.
Aber eigentlich dafür, dass du alleine bist, kommst du ja ganz gut klar gegen drei Leute. Jetzt hier so...
Ja, mich kriegt er eh nicht umgepustet. Ich weiß ja, dass ich recht hab. Und das ist das entscheidende Ding. Also man kann halt nicht aufhören. Man muss einfach immer ein bisschen Zukunft gestalten. Heißt halt auch, darüber nachdenken. Und da eine...
Und Forderungen formulieren.
Ja genau, man muss halt auch ausprobieren. Man kann ja auch scheitern. Scheitern ist ja jetzt sozusagen nichts schlechtes. Scheitern ist super. Weil Scheitern heißt, man hat es zumindest probiert. Aber wenn man sich hinsetzt und sagt so... Mexikaner.
Dann wird da nichts draus.
Ich finde das ein bisschen zu schwarz und weiß gesehen. Es gibt noch Wahrheiten dazwischen.
Kann schon sein.
Prove me wrong.
Nicht alles, was nach einer schlechten Idee klingt, muss ausprobiert werden.
Ach ihr alten Miesmacher. Ich hab euch trotzdem lieb. Wollen wir die Sendung noch optimistisch zu Ende führen?
Wenn du das hinkriegst.
Du bist doch schon betrunken.
Ich hab mich extra zurückgehalten für die Sendung.
Eine Stunde überzogen.
Das Betrinken, das geht ja jetzt los in der Lounge.
Aber wir können ja das erstmal alle machen.
Naja, das machen wir hier gleich mit unseren Freunden hier vor Ort zu ändern.
Okay.
Soll einfach auf die Bühne kommen oder was?
Nee, wir müssen jetzt erstmal die Sendung sozusagen auch zu einem Ende führen.
Zu einem positiven. Dieser Mexikaner ist mir am Hals stecken geblieben.
Wir haben euch alle lieb und einhörner. Ist das positiv?
Ich hab euch kaputt gespielt.
Ich merke es sofort.
Nee, hast du nicht. Aber spiel mal ab oder was auch immer du da hast.
Ich weiß nicht. Ich hab nur noch so ein bisschen so einen kleinen Weihnachtsausklang mir noch gesucht, der zum Thema passt. Ja.
Das ist noch fast zwölf Monate hin, Mann.
Ich brauch jetzt mal wieder meinen Screen hier irgendwie. Ja klar, ich meine, ihr habt ja jetzt keine nennenswerten Ideen mehr auf den Tisch.
Wieso, wir reden noch die ganze Zeit auf dich ein und du?
Du, ich hab hier jede Menge Hardware auf die Bühne geschleppt.
Ja, ist ja gut. Aber hast du noch welche zu zeigen? Nee, ist doch alles durch.
Ich hab meinen Soll erfüllt, glaube ich.
Ja genau, wir haben alle unseren Soll erfüllt.
Na dann.
Und deswegen würde ich sagen, fangen wir ja langsam mal an, das Ende einzuleiten. Achso, dazu muss ich ja auch noch mal hier.
Das ist natürlich, jedes Ende ist natürlich auch ein Anfang.
Ja, um jetzt nochmal die positive Note mit dem letzten.
Genau.
Nach dem Ende ist vor dem Anfang.
Womit ich meine, wir treffen uns alle gleich in der Lounge und haben Spaß.
Genau, das ist das, was wir machen. Und ansonsten würde ich mal sagen, bedanken wir uns mal erstmal hier bei euch, ja, für das tolle Mitmachen und das tolle Feedback geben, Sachen schicken und was nicht alles ist super. Macht richtig großen Spaß mit der ganzen Community, diese Sendung zu machen und wir machen weiter. Und mit der 200, müsst ihr mal ein paar gute Ideen bringen und vielleicht decken wir uns noch was raus.
Keiner tippt Kopfhörer. Drahtlos mit Leuchttioden.
Ja, ich brauch den Link. Ich suche auch noch mal das Video raus.
Die Seidenstraße ist wieder am Start.
So, wieso höre ich jetzt eigentlich nichts hier?
Letztes Jahr war mehr la meta.
Mein Audio ist nicht an, kann das sein?
Leute, rot, ich versuche hier eine professionelle...
Eine normale Freak Show. Jedes Mal.
Habt ihr mich drauf oder nicht?
Jedes Mal.
Jaja, ist Bild in Output.
Ich hatte gerade so einen Knistern irgendwie auf dem Kopf.
Du hast einen Knistern im... Macht mich fertig. Ja, ich weiß nicht, spielt jetzt nicht. Siehst du mal? Ich hatte Recht, ne?
So, so endet die Sendung.
Natürlich.
Huckel.
Das war Huckel, die Stimme der Jugend. Dennis, Bitcoin-Millionär. Roddy das Einhorn. Und ich, Tim, vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Hat Spaß gemacht.
Bis bald.
Willkommen.
Thank you for coming.